The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series
that will air in 2022, House of the Dragon,
although based on George RR Martin's Targaryen
history book Fire & Blood, will not feature
Targaryens only, but many other houses and
many other legendary figures from that time
period as well. Beside Targaryens, we will
have important Starks, Lannisters, Baratheons,
Tyrells but also Hightowers. Although Hightowers
existed in Game of Thrones as well, we had
no important Hightowers in it. In House of
the Dragon on the other hand, Hightowers play
the biggest role alongside Targaryens.
It's Otto Hightower (the Hand of the King)
and his daughter Alicent Hightower
(wife of King Viserys Targaryen with whom
she has children) that basically started the
Dance of the Dragons, Targaryen civil war.
The key event of the show is also the key
in the history of House Targaryen, the Dance
of the Dragons - the Targaryen civil war,
which divided the entire kingdom and launched
a huge war that was fought from 129 AC to
131 AC.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Ser Otto
Hightower was a knight from House Hightower
who served as Hand of the King to three kings,
although two of the kings removed him from
office at various times. He was the younger
brother of Lord Hightower, and the uncle of
Lord Ormund Hightower of Oldtown. His children
included Alicent Hightower, the second queen
of King Viserys I Targaryen, and Ser Gwayne
Hightower, second in command of the gold cloaks.
Otto is remembered as a warning that knowledge
is not everything. Otto Hightower fights or
should I say serves on the behalf of his grandson,
Aegon II Targaryens against Rhaenyra Targaryen.
Ser Otto first served as Hand of the King
after the death of Prince Baelon Targaryen,
the Hand and son of King Jaehaerys I Targaryen.
Otto effectively ruled the Seven Kingdoms
as Hand in the final two years of Jaehaerys's
reign, while his daughter, Alicent Hightower,
nursed the ailing king. Otto continued as
Hand to Jaehaerys's grandson and successor
on the throne, Viserys I Targaryen. He became
a bitter rival of the king's brother, Prince
Daemon Targaryen, who had been named master
of coin. Otto convinced the king to remove
him from office and did so again when Viserys
named Daemon master of laws. He came to regret
this, however, when Daemon was named commander
of the City Watch, as this put two thousand
men under Daemon's command and the prince
thrived in this new office. Otto feared Daemon
would become a second Maegor the Cruel if
he ever ascended to the Iron Throne, sharing
his fears with his brother, the Lord of the
Hightower. Thus, by this time, Otto wished
for Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen to succeed
her father. Otto's daughter Alicent became
King Viserys's second wife in 106 AC, after
the death of Queen Aemma Arryn. In 109 AC,
Otto was removed as the Hand for hounding
Viserys to declare Alicent's sons the heirs
to the Iron Throne instead of Princess Rhaenyra.
Having no place at court anymore, Otto returned
to Oldtown. A "queen's party", known as the
greens, the group of powerful lords who were
friends with Queen Alicent, remained, who
supported the rights of Alicent's sons. In
120 AC, Otto returned as Hand after Lord Lyonel
Strong died. When Viserys died in 129 AC,
Otto played a crucial role in crowning his
eldest grandson as King Aegon II in defiance
of the last will of Viserys I, which specified
Rhaenyra as the successor. This defiance precipitated
the civil war known as the Dance of the Dragons.
The Dance of the Dragons began with Otto serving
as Hand of the King to Aegon II Targaryen.
According to Orwyle, Otto ordered the confinement
of Lord Lyman Beesbury in the black cells.
Ser Gwayne Hightower, Otto's son, was named
as the second in command of the gold cloaks,
behind Ser Luthor Largent. The blacks, Rhaenyra
Targaryen's faction opposing Aegon's greens,
included the battle-tested Prince Daemon Targaryen,
who, in the course of his pre-war adventures,
had made many foes, including Otto. After
the death of Prince Jaehaerys Targaryen at
the hands of Daemon's assassins, Blood and
Cheese, Aegon ordered deaths of King's Landing's
ratcatchers. Otto brought a hundred cats to
the Red Keep. Otto reached out to other enemies
of the prince Daemon, the Kingdom of the Three
Daughters, as allies. They were crucial in
breaking the Velaryon blockade in the Battle
of the Gullet. Otto was unsuccessful in gaining
an alliance with Qoren Martell, the Prince
of Dorne. King Aegon II told his grandfather
"Thrones are won with swords, not quills.
Spill blood, not ink." Aegon II perceived
Otto's diplomacy as slothful at a time when
Prince Daemon had captured Harrenhal and many
houses had declared for the blacks. This led
to Otto's replacement as the Hand by Ser Criston
Cole, the Lord Commander of the Kingsguard,
despite the pleading of Queen Alicent Hightower,
Otto's daughter and Aegon's mother. It was
only after his dismissal that Otto's diplomatic
efforts bore fruit. Just as he had predicted,
Otto was the first to be beheaded as a traitor
by Rhaenyra after the fall of King's Landing
in 130 AC, which was not the end of the Targaryen
civil war, as Rhaenyra later loses Kings Landing,
but it was the end for Otto Hightower. Actor
Rhys Ifans will play a role of Otto Hightower
in House of the Dragon. HBO's official description
of the character reads:
"The Hand of the King, who loyally and faithfully
serves both his king and his realm. As the
Hand sees it, the greatest threat to the realm
is the king's brother, Daemon, and his position
as heir to the throne."
The show will stay true to the books in this
matter, Otto's greatest rival in the books
was Prince Daemon Targaryen and he will also
be in the show. But most of the other things
however will differ from the books.
Not only will there be differences between
the books and the show like it was with Game
of Thrones, but after reading the book Fire
And Blood, you still don't know how most of
the events really played out.
Some would think that you could just read
the book Fire & Blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book,
but that’s far from true. Why? Because Fire
And Blood is not a conventional novel, it
is an imaginary history book, and according
to George RR Martin himself, not very accurate
at that. Because while Fire And blood book
was written by George RR Martin, it was not
written from him as facts, but rather through
the perspective of the Citadel's Archmaester
Gyldayn who gathered all info and as many
different sources as he could and used it
to write a book about the Targaryen history.
Some info is fake, some info is true, some
info is semi-true. No one will know for a
fact what was happening in real history until
the House of the Dragon airs in 2022.
The show unlike the book will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi-true, not
what might or might not have happened. Fire
& Blood is a complete history of House Targaryen
written by George R. R. Martin from the perspective
of Archmaester Gyldayn who wrote it many decades
after the events took place. Sure, most of
the main events such as battles and deaths
probably did happen, but as Gyldayn says it
in the books, the full truth about what happened
behind closed doors, in the privacy of stairwells,
council rooms, and bedchambers he does not
fully know and he turns to many different
sources which usually differ from one another.
He looks into the course of chronicles laid
down by Grand Maester Runciter and his successors
and many court documents as well. Gyldayn
looks into accounts written decades later
by children and grandchildren of those caught
up in the events of these times. While they
are undoubtedly of use, so much time has passed
between the event and the recording that many
confusions and contradictions have inevitably
crept in.Unfortunately this is also true for
Gyldayn's two accounts by firsthand observers
that have come down to him. Septon Eustace
who served in the royal sept in the Red Keep
during much of this time and spent much time
as a confidant and confessor to King Viserys
and his queens. His account is biased, favoring
Aegon II over Rhaenyra. The second account
is based upon a verbal account of the court
fool Mushroom who was present at court for
all of them; for King Viserys, Princess and
Queen Rhaenyra and both King Aegons, the Second
and the Third. During his reign, King Baelor
I Targaryen had Mushroom's book burned on
account of its scandalous content. There are
several main sources for historical information
on the Dance of the Dragons, which are frequently
at odds with each other. Gyldayn also uses
source written by Grand Maester Orwyle, who
had served King Aegon II Targaryen on his
council
and was arrested by the forces of Queen Rhaenyra
Targaryen when she took the city. Orwyle wrote
his account while locked away in the black
cells. Uncertain about whether or not he would
survive the war, he attempted to paint himself
in the best light possible. Grand Maester
Munkun's The Dance of the Dragons, A True
Telling was based on Orwyle's account. Using
all these sources which often differ from
one another, archmaester Gyldayn wrote his
work, Fire And Blood, his work about the history
of House Targaryen. This format brings up
Martin's major thematic point about the uncertainty
of memory, and history being written by winners.
Neither side truly won the war, and decades
after the war, both sides wrote their own
biased history books trying to put their actions
in a better light. Thus histories written
by the Greens depict Aegon II in good light
and Rhaenyra in a bad light. On the other
hand, histories written by the Blacks do the
opposite. We'll know exactly what happened
in this time period when the show airs, and
that’s why you cannot just read the book
Fire And Blood and think you would know what
actually happened or what will happen on the
show. Books are written by Archmaester decades
and decades after the events took place, using
many sources that in most cases are very different
from each other and most of them are biased
as well.
What we can tell you for a fact is that House
of the Dragon starts filming in around 3 weeks
and will air in 2022 on HBO. We can also tell
you that Otto Hightower will play a huge role.
He's the grandfather of Aegon II and he (alongside
his daughter Queen Alicent) starts Targaryen
civil war. The war began when King Viserys
I died, started by the Greens, Otto and Alicent
Hightower among others by disobeying King
Viserys' orders of crowning Rhaenyra and instead
crowning Aegon as the new King of Westeros.
The same day that Viserys I died, Aegon II's
followers, the Greens, staged a coup, and
he was soon crowned in King's Landing. Rhaenyra,
as the Princess of Dragonstone, had her powerbase
on Dragonstone island, where she responded
by being crowned queen by Daemon and declaring
Aegon a traitor. Thus the Targaryen civil
war began. Thank you so much for watching,
hope you enjoyed this video and if you did
make sure to give it a big thumbs upand I
hope to see you in the next one, peace!